[Music]
Los Angeles good views here we are
Beverly Hills bad traffic so many
electric vehicle Chargers Charger number
one 2 3 from the streets of downtown to
the beach in Santa Monica 11 19 23 we
visited 30 DC fast charging locations
none of them run by Tesla 28 29 30 that
meant more than 100 different charging
stalls there was just one little problem
yeah this one's broken broken and also
broken okay many problems come on you
can do it connect to the vehic error
detected there's nothing on the screen
I've tried putting my credit card in
every way at just over 40% of the
charging locations I encountered
problems yeah not good as the US moves
to an electric vehicle future La is
ahead of it all but oh boy are things a
mess here what can we learn from it all
and can it be fixed all right let's go
test a whole bunch of
chargers here's how we set up this
test Los Angeles County has more DC fast
Chargers than any other place in the
country so over 2 days I tried to go to
as many as I could in a rivan
r1t why the rivan well it's awesome
unless you're trying to enter a parking
garage okay dock down
I'm totally aware that ducking does
nothing plus like the majority of non-
Tesla EVS it has a CCS charging port
when you've got that port and you need
to charge a DC fast charging station
typically an EVO or Electrify America is
your best bet except those stations
according to my testing have three main
problems number one out of
order I inspected 126 charging stalls in
total 27% % of those stalls were just
flat out of order that is they had a
sign or an error that said charger
unavailable out of service so it works
Evo Electrify America and evcs all told
me that they quickly try to fix these
issues by deploying technicians to the
sites but honestly I preferred this
issue because it saved me from the
hassle of trying the charger and then
failing which brings me to number two
payment nearly 10% of the Stalls visited
had payment issues it says cash
only where would I put cash yes there
were specifically repeated credit card
problems why are you beeping at me
present card
again okay nope let's see if this will
work now it's telling me to swipe the
card present card again swiping card
present card
again try another card wiping my other
card nope nothing evcs said these issues
can arise because the payment Hardware
is made by a different company than the
charger EV go said paying by app is a
more seamless experience and I found
that app paying was better for all the
Chargers some EVs and charging companies
even support plug-in charge so it just
starts charging your account when you
plug into your car but you still have to
set those apps up why don't you take
Apple pay number three connection issues
even if the payment works it is
connecting now to my vehicle can you two
connect charger meet rivan rivan meet
charger connect error detected this may
be the most frustrating one of all when
the car and the charger don't connect to
each other what many call the handshake
issue basically when you plug the
charger into the car the two have to
talk to each other and send information
about voltage and energy levels back and
forth and a lot can go wrong in this
process I'll get to more of that soon
sometimes the charger will prompt you
with ways to troublesho please unplug
the connector wait 10 seconds plug in
the connector and try again I will try
to unplug and replug like a router but
it doesn't always work and to be fair
this handshake issue isn't just a rivan
thing I've experienced this problem on
many different
EVS to find out why this is all such a
broken I met up with charger help an LA
based company that attempts to clean up
the mass so you fix Chargers yes there a
lot of broken Chargers yeah no we fix a
lot of chargers in La especially with
our La technicians that we have here
Sergio one of the charger help
technicians walked me through fixing one
stall it shows that it has a fault here
so a power cycle the unit we can go
ahead and hit the breaker to shut it off
yep as simple as turning it off and
turning it on again
so we're getting the green uh prompt
lights which means the charging station
is back online but most repairs are not
that simple because again the car and
the charger are computers that have to
communicate with each other this is the
whole motherboard here which uh
sometimes goes bad and we have to
replace Sergio explained that this set
of cables connect from the motherboard
to the charger to communicate with the
car it's that handshake I mentioned
before the charger tells the car how
much voltage it can send and the car
says hey here's how much I can accept
but that's where things can break down
sometimes the network where you're at
whichever area you're in it's poor so
you have to try it multiple times so it
actually ends up working if you notice
when you try it like the third or fourth
time it ends up actually working and
remember the DC fast Chargers I tested
have to communicate with lots of
different types of electric vehicles
which is why things can get so much more
complicated than on Tesla's Network so
it's one station trying to figure out
how to communicate with multiple
different types of firmware whereas if
you have a Tesla system it's a
vertically integrated where they have a
car a station and a payment system
that's all
together so what's the future of EV
charging starting in 2024 Tesla's
opening up its charging Network allowing
cars from rivan Ford NGM and others to
charge at Tesla stations doesn't fit at
least not yet eventually those car
companies will also adopt Tesla's nacs
charging port will it be total
hassle-free charging I'm not so sure
Tesla is only used to charging their own
cars and those other DC fast charging
stations from Evo Electrify America and
more should get better too at an EO
station in Santa Monica I got to try out
some newer charging stalls it says
checking cable safety matching voltage
this tells you what it's doing these new
machines are
great representatives from each of the
charger companies told me many of the
issues I encountered were because of
Legacy hardware and that they are
constantly upgrading which we actually
saw at this Electrify
America knock knock is there a charger
in there plus in September the Biden
Administration opened up $100 million in
federal funding to repair and replace
existing electric vehicle charging
infrastructure that's an addition to the
$5 billion program to help States build
out more EV charging sites with should
help with the lines excuse
me are you guys almost done charging so
what did I learn here over the last few
days well if you can charge at home or
your hotel yet I met many Travelers and
apartment renters who don't have that
option really what I learned is patience
have a lot of it when pulling into one
of these stations and understand that
this isn't as simple as plugging your
phone into the wall oh and avoid credit
cards when ever possible just use that
charger's mobile app but if La is any
sign this Eevee Revolution is going to
feel more like a slow messy Evolution
charging
woohoo at least that's what it
says 20 we hit 20 you like this dance
it's really cool